and today hundreds of thousands of
students are unable to attend classes
because of a three-day strike in the
second largest school district in the
country support staff are leading this
strike in Los Angeles 35 000 teachers
joining them in solidarity the workers
say that their salaries are so low that
many are at risk of living on the
streets Carter Evans is covering this
for us in Los Angeles Carter good
morning
Good morning Tony this is a school bus
yard behind me and as you can see
picketers are out in force here and
they're planning to be out in force
around Los Angeles today 30 thousand
workers for the union representing
support staff like teachers aides bus
drivers custodians they're planning to
strike for three days also teachers from
the school district are planning to join
in in solidarity so that means hundreds
of thousands of kids will not be going
to school for the next couple of days
now the news comes after failed
negotiations between the district and
the union earlier on Monday the union
wants a 30 percent raise now they say
average salaries for support staff total
about 25 000 a year and that puts many
of them below the poverty line
especially when you factor in inflation
and the rising cost of housing the
school district is countered with a 23
percent raise offer and a cash bonus and
says the door is open to continue
negotiations now Los Angeles is the
second largest school district in the
country so this is going to impact about
a half million students and in
preparation for all of this about a
thousand schools are going to be open
today but with no educational staff so
there's not going to be any instruction
just some supervision also here in Los
Angeles many families depend on the
school district for meals for their
children so there will be food
distribution sites around the county for
the next three days and of course you
can see all this rain here we've got
another one of those atmospheric Rivers
coming through so it is going to be a
very wet day on the picket lines
all right Carter thank you very much